[موسيقى]
نجمه كبيره بمسيره حافله جسدت خلالها
العديد من الشخصيات الكوميديه وصفق لها
الجمهور طويلا امام الشاشات لكنها كانت
بين الفنانات الاكثر شعبيه والاقل حظا على
منصات التتويج لولا ان الحظ قرر ان يبتسم
لها اخيرا انها جنيفر كوليج التي اقترن
اسمها مؤخرا باهم الجوائز الفنيه خلال
العامين الاخيرين فما قصتها
ولدت جينيفر كوليدج عام
1961 في بوسطن وكان والدها يعمل في تصنيع
البلاستيك فيما كانت احلامها تتوجه صوب
الفن فعزفت على اله الكلارينات في معسكرات
الاوركسترا خلال عطله المدارس الصيفيه ثم
درست المسرح وحصلت فيه على درجه
البكالوريوس ثم انضمت الى فريق مسرح غوثام
سيتي قبل ان تنتقل الى لوس انجلوس وتنضم
لفرقه ذا جرا للتمثيل الكوميدي خلال تلك
الفتره عاشت جينيفر تجربه سلبيه في حياتها
عندما بدات بطاعات الكوكايين واعتادت
الاحتفال في الانديه الليليه بشكل دائم
اثر ذلك على مسيرتها المهنيه حيث نقلت عده
مرات الى غرف الطوارئ بسبب الادمان قبل ان
تخضع للتاهيل وهي في سن السابعه والعشرين
من عمرها وتتخلى عن هذه العادات
في عام
1993 ظهرت كوليج لاول مره على شاشه
التلفاز كضيفه عرض لمسلسل ساينفيلد ثم
قدمت ادوارا خجوله حيث ظهرت كوليج لاول
مره على شاشه الكبيره كممرضه في فيلم
قبل ان تنضم لاسره مسلسل الكوميديا
كممثله وكاتبه في عام
1996 في عام
1999 عرف الجمهور جينيفر من خلال شخصيه
جنين ستايلر في فيلم الكوميديا امريكان
باي الذي ظهرت فيه بموسم اخر عام 2002 كما
قدمت اداء ناجحا عندما لعبت دور فنيه
اظافر في نسختي فيلم الكوميديا بلوند 2
لكنها نجحت من خلال الشخصيات الكوميديه
التي قدمتها بنجاح
في فيلم السندريلا ستوري ووتني تايلر
فيدوريشن
في عام 2021 فاجات جينيفر جمهورها عندما
تركت الكوميديا جانبا وظهرت بشخصيه الام
القلقه في فيلم
لكن المفاجاه الاكبر عندما بدات تحصد ثمار
نجاحاتها بعد ان ظهرت في فيلم دراما
والكوميديا وايت لوتس
2 وحققت نجاحا كبيرا وبدات تقطف ثمار
سنوات طويله من العمل
خلال العامين الماضيين تلقت جينيفر
ارشادات واسعه وحصلت على عدد كبير من
الجوائز التي لم تحققها من قبل ففازت
بجائزه
اختيار النقاد وجائزه الاكاديميه
الاستراليه للفنون كافضل ممثله في مسلسل
وافضل ممثله داعمه ببرنامج تلفزيوني
وجائزه ديربي الذهبيه وغيرها
تمتلك جينيفر كوليد اليوم ثروه تقدر بنحو
سته ملايين دولار ولكنها تملك ايضا قلوب
الكثير من محبي الكوميديا العالميه وهي
الثروه التي تجعلها نجمه متوقده وهي في
الثانيه والستين من عمرها